when you put the dab on it are you
supposed to eat the dab too you know
that's how it
goes only so what is this this is the
killer this is the last day why are you
opening it all right
John
yeah okay is this went bad what do you
mean what do you mean by shaking it what
are you doing what do you mean what do
you what do you
mean what do you mean why I'm shaking it
you got to shake it oh like Daddy needs
a new pair of shoes oh Jesus oh this is
an application moment so this is the
last dab we call it the last dab cuz
it's traditional on here to put a little
extra on the last one you don't have to
if you don't want to what extra you
don't have to if you don't want to I am
not going to do what you just did yeah
yeah that I think is for the best and
don't you worry about it oh I'm not
worried at all don't let it Avalanche
but is this not coming in that's too
much well wherever you go is where I go
get a bit aggressive Slow
Hands well done sh you know they say
tradition is peer pressure from dead
people yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay that's dab there you go there you
man I'm getting in there bump oh
shoot all right
whatever I'm showing out today yeah for
Real come on Salute hey what a run
absolutely look at us right look at us
who would have thought who have thought
this has been fun and I hope to never
see you ever again
okay I
know going
in perfect
perfect
unbelievable what a
performance get another pan
down bye see you on the other
side yeah right right
right kind of a God I know I know I know
a low
lift I know I know woo but you did
it you got it you got it I know I know
hit in the lap be careful M you're tall
watch out for the boom up
there all
right oh oh no it's not even about the
spiciness it's just like the taste of it
it just tastes
like yeah yeah yeah yeah I caught that
right yeah go again do that
again I've seen you like this man the
the ears you know what I mean are you
all right I can I'm going to make it I'm
going to make I'm not all right together
you know we're in the same way you know
what we all we're all in
S I always love eating H but not this
time today not today no sure not today
the good news is we have slayed the hot
sauce Dragon we're done this Inferno
match our version of an Inferno match
we've survived it we've conquered it and
just one more hoop before we get you out
of here with the heat of a Million Suns
coursing through your veins right now do
you have any foundational advice for
people struggling with feelings of
inadequacy even when their lives are
seemingly otherwise going well um that
is such a good question and you asked it
at a complete wrong time I don't know
how you talk coherently during this so
my hat's off um thank you and to close
things out what I want to do is put you
to the test a little bit we have a
couple pairs of drumsticks here I'm
curious if you can teach me some sort of
drumstick trick but we have a little
sketch pad and we would be so honored so
what we have here is a full Misan PL no
way okay are you serious you playing
this ahead time you're the only one who
could stop
you
you know as any kind of artist you are
the one who says it's enough that's
going to make me cry because the wings
didn't it make me cry but that might
make me cry and man there just there's
nothing but love like and all those
people who said that they hate you while
they eat These Wings [__] them [__] them
I got your back [__] like I got your
back byy Fair imperfect shade through
heavy sleep on sightless eyeses doth
stay all days are nights to see till I
see thee and night's bright days when
dreams do show thee me Sterling K Brown
you doth crush the wings of death today
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera or this
camera or this camera there's a lot of
cameras today let the people know what
you have going on in your life thank you
so much what do you mean you have a
movie coming out or anything oh oh why
we're here right now my ass is going to
be on fire I can't wait wait I'm just
happy that I'm just happy that I'm going
to make my fans
happy wow uh 9:00 Thursday nights I'm
sorry that's
Tuesdays bundle coming out and um right
now this month some days I forgot the
[__] dates now I'm so tripping on
this no let me do it again I can't even
think MH it's a miracle I speak English
right now take two well hello America
well you know what I learned about you
today that you are brave that you are a
warrior we crushed wings of that you
know what I think just happened what I
attacked the shark
you I think I'm going to go to the
Whitney Museum this afternoon unless I
uh [__]
myself
goodbye
than